Karen jeanpierre spokesman for the
president was just asked to explain why
the economy is so bad all this time into
the Biden Administration and she gave a
fivelet answer why do you think it is
that when you say the economy is
improving and President Biden says the
economy is improving that a majority of
Americans outside of this building are
not buying it so here's the
thing when we walked into this
Administration the economy was on a tail
a tail spin that is the fact because the
last administration because of the Trump
administration because of how they dealt
with uh with dealt with covid and the
pandemic this is even worse than the
usual just blame the last guy routine
Karine Jean Pierre is blaming Trump for
losing certain battles to Democrats like
Joe Biden